we are we are back here Ava having known
Donald Trump before he entered politics
do you think there is another side of
him we don't see what was he like before
that Wow
I don't know him well but I will say I
will say never try to grab your [ __ ] no
no reasonable question not but I was
like yeah he was on the apprentice when
I was on housewives and and I did a
charity event for a documentary I did
about farmworkers in New York and so my
PR company kind of just invited New
Yorkers and he couldn't calm I guess
they invited him he couldn't come and he
sent me a note and he said so sorry I
can't be there and he sent me a check he
wrote he don't he'd made a donation to
Latinos a check from his personal
encounter I can't remember I was trying
to think that it was probably from the
foundation yeah probably so con where he
doesn't spend his own money and pretends
he does right well he yeah well we did
donate I was like oh that and I always
remembered oh that was so nice and then
I see him when he announced his
presidency yeah I was like oh well who's
that Tim Ryan do you see much hope for
an improved food system under President
Trump well we didn't get one under
President Obama I was one of my
questions when I interviewed him I asked
him about the purity of the food system
you know things yeah never gets asked
yeah and I see why cuz he didn't really
answer the question well not to my
satisfaction I mean when you look at the
appointment for the EPA you look for the
opponent to holding a part of
Agriculture a total big AG you know
reducing regulations for like healthy
food we had a monsanto guy guarding a
store item right I agree I agree
Democrats I think this is a good issue
for Democrats to talk about how we
change the food system how we get
locally local food into our schools
we're poisoning our kids right now with
art with what we feed them
we have we have huge rates of diabetes
it's driving up the Medicare program
it's driving up the cost of the Medicaid
program and if we want to get it right
we've got to start getting healthy food
into our schools so our kids won't have
diabetes it'll bring the cost of the
healthcare program down and free up more
money for education free college
debt-free college clean pipes across the
United States and all these things we
got to get to health care on a
reasonable liberal pagina that is cut a
brutalized cup of tea to stretch it
Richard Haass do you think it was
appropriate for representative Tulsi
Gabbard she's been on a showed to meet
with President Assad on a recent trip to
Syria should we meet with dictators or
just Putin's not funny I would not have
met with Bashar al-assad at this time
he's committed all sorts of war crimes
more than half of this country is
displaced 500,000 people have died the
eye our goal should be only that he gets
out of power was stuck with them for the
time being the real question you know I
actually think for President Obama the
sad and most critical part of his legacy
will be all the stuff he didn't do we
went from a president who arguably did
too much in Iraq to a president who did
way too little in Syria I would refer to
do their well among other things when
Syrian Jews chemical weapons we could
have attacked their Air Force we could
have done more to help we attack their
effort what nice is to take a number the
country that by early on we actually had
lots of options to work with the
opposition or if you thought that was a
decision who was the opposition which
Sunni groups we could have worked with
but if you think that if you think that
then why would you save an us on there
was no moderate that's the problem in
the Middle East
fine fine the moderate Serrano mob they
don't exactly they'd only plant but you
find out let's write you but you've got
to choose your poisons you find less
radical or if you think that but Dad you
don't say Assad must go
pratik then you know my dad wound up
with like 50 guys nobody that was late
in the process earlier on we had bigger
options and if we had acted decisively I
actually think we could have changed the
dynamics what it shows is that what you
don't do in foreign policy can be every
bit as consequential as what you do do
okay John do you think it was
appropriate for BuzzFeed to publish the
dossier on Trump's ties to Russia
right that's a good question would you
as editor-in-chief of The Daily Beast
have done that I wouldn't have we had we
had looks at that and made it a
different decision but I you know it's
not I understand why they did it I think
it ultimately though is used by Trump as
a cudgel to criticize all the media
right that becomes the thin edge of the
wedge for them to say all news is fake
news and and BuzzFeed does a lot of good
reporting and when all of a sudden they
started attacking CNN and BuzzFeed and
The Daily Beast which was you know one
of the first places blacklisted which we
think is a badge of honor their whole
goal is to convince everybody that's
fake news and then to elevate propaganda
outlets that are doing their bidding
that muddying of the line between truth
and lies with journalism is one of the
most dangerous things that's going to be
going on the next for you
okay can we expect that protests like
the recent women's March will continue
throughout Trump's presidency and will
they make a difference I hope so because
if not it's not that they will continue
I hope they continue I hope it's not a
moment that it's a movement and and what
what I hope is the way the Tea Party did
it and they were much smaller than the
people that that came out on Saturday I
mean the Tea Party was this big and we
drove her to it
Occupy Wall Street because I was here
that's a good question because I feel
like Occupy Wall Street was short-lived
because there was no focus there was
what was the agenda what are what are we
what do we do who was in charge of it
and it kind of just fizzled out and
that's what I think cannot happen with
this movement especially with the
women's with with the women's March is
what do we want because there was such a
cross-section of intersex there was an
intersection of people that came out to
the March it was it was black white
young old Republican Democrat many
people were it started from this
inspiring movement of I don't want my
rights rolled back I don't want to limit
women's rights I want an expansion of
women's right people pay the stories
that
one that I'm not happy I'm gonna I mean
if you think old media matters anymore
240 newspapers endorsed Hillary Clinton
and she lost and one grandma in Hawaii
writes let's start a March and it's the
biggest contest where American action I
think that tells you about social mainly
the people who March didn't vote it's
how many if it's not we don't know that
but but what we do know is that there is
an election coming up right November
everybody has insane I hope from that
Saturday on let's hope but we can we can
use it in the midterm if the message in
that 2018 election is Republicans are
still getting elected under the trump
presidency then work out you got a
problem three-quarters you have the
Senate seats that are up or Democratic
seats right Democrats are just
disadvantaged structurally go yeah but
there's there's a lot of Governor seats
that are up and if we win governor's
races this is where Democrats kind of
forget to vote and off your elections be
organized and off your I think this
we're going to rebut it is select that's
true right but but if you look if you
look at the numbers I mean in Ohio
Michigan Wisconsin how do you think
Scott Walker keeps getting elected
because people don't you know but when
the presidential in Wisconsin usually
aunt but Scott Walker wins if you win
those governor races you start adjusting
the map for the House of Representatives
you can pick up two or three seats in
Ohio two or three seats in Michigan
maybe a couple in Wisconsin all of a
sudden you start trying to unlock some
of us you guys you guys have it
backwards all of this focus on Trump
which you do and others do so that's the
big change I know but the Faubourg don't
rather it's actually easy not to if you
focus on what what's happened in the
last eight years the Republicans did the
long march through the institution's
there are thirty three Republican
governors they're twenty five states
that have a Republican governor in both
houses twenty five we did have a
majority of the country living in the
other or not the square States out west
these are big states and then we go gee
how did Trump win in North Carolina and
Florida and Ohio and Wisconsin and
Michigan well we've had a Republican
governor in both houses of the
legislature there for six to eight years
in these states these states
some Republican are strengthening their
Republican roots and Trump came in and
once
well it wasn't turning off their Trump
was not driving the lower but here in
roots as so much as fixing and rigging
the game so that Democrats can't vote
that's what they do it's not that people
want to be more Republican Donald Trump
proved people don't even like
Republicans because he's not a
Republican like I look at the enemies
layaway why you're losing elections
you're never going to get to win them I
mean you really need to figure out why
you've been losing that's acknowledge
that a date Legislative roses we've got
to do a better job weeks on Halloween
look at the economy in Ohio like up with
tents you know high was growing at half
of the national average we've got a ton
of problems you look at Indiana same
thing with pence did Indiana their
economies not well look at what
Brownback did in Kansas he's destroyed
the entire state and got reelected same
in Wisconsin I mean Trump was bashing
Scott Walker during the primary because
was Branson's economy sucks so these
Republican governors aren't doing a very
good job that it's a hell of an
opportunity for us to go alright week
one we live Pruett thank you everybody
[Applause]